hi
welcome to another episode of cold
fusion where i cover anything in science
technology business or history on march
29th 2022 cnn launched cnn plus a
venture that was going to be the future
of the company it was a
subscription-based digital platform with
a one billion dollar budget over four
years
but the entire venture catastrophically
collapsed in just three weeks
so what happened and what can we learn
here let's take a look
you are watching cold fusion tv
founded in 1980 cnn has traditionally
been the network that viewers turned to
in times of war terrorism or major news
but after 40 years things have started
to change
cnn's core news business has been
failing spectacularly in february of
2022 the company lost 70 percent of its
primetime viewers in its key demographic
this comes at a time when trust and
media is at its all-time low dropping
from 76 in 2016 down to 58 in 2021
not only this but there's been multiple
scandals involving key cnn staff from
affairs to child abuse the pressure was
too much for ceo jeff zucker and he was
forced to resign earlier this year
so how was cnn going to turn all of this
around the world was moving towards
streaming platforms so why not cnn
besides they're the biggest name in news
what could possibly go wrong
cnn is an icon of the cable and
satellite age but now cable is competing
with streaming and there isn't a
streaming subscription service for tv
news in the united states so if you were
creating a news product from scratch in
2022 how would you build it that's one
of the questions one of the starting
points for cnn plus the result was cnn
plus
what followed was a multi-million dollar
ad campaign millions more were spent on
hiring staff to produce exclusive
content
in total 300 million dollars was spent
building up the service
for viewers the subscription cost was
six dollars per month
the problems visibly began to be evident
with the branding of cnn plus a lot of
viewers thought the service was mostly
going to be exclusive live news but in
reality it was a bit of a mixed bag
although the focus was news cnn plus's
lineup included a cooking show a book
club show with jake tapper a show about
past movie stars another show about the
singer dione warwick and an anderson
cooper program about the challenges of
being a dad
frankly nobody cared about these things
but that was just the start of the
trouble
interestingly according to the new york
times it looks as if cnn plus may have
been thrown under the bus internally
you see just before the launch of cnn
plus cnn who was owned by warner media
was going through massive changes
warner brothers and hence warner media
was undergoing a merge with the
discovery company
and the thing is both companies already
had ventures in the streaming world
discovery had the discovery plus
streaming service and warner media had
hbo max
both of these streaming services were
about to be bundled into one leaving no
room for poor cnn plus
discovery executives were all skeptical
of cnn plus from the beginning in fact
before its launch the discovery managers
refused to have meetings with the cnn
plus officials to even hear what the
product was about
and this didn't happen just once this
happened three times
they just didn't care about it
internal problems aside the project was
a complete flop
executives expected 2 million
subscribers in the first year but cnn
plus only managed 10 000 consistent
viewers after the first two weeks and
that was even after lowering the price
when david zaslov the new ceo of the
warner brothers discovery merger saw the
abysmal numbers for the first time he
was appalled he made the decision to
shut it down instantly
to him cnn plus was taking up a lot of
resources and giving nothing in return
in total after 300 million dollars spent
the service was only around for three
weeks and the explosion left a trail of
destruction in its wake layoffs ensued
and the disaster upended the careers of
many would-be hopefuls this is going to
be our last episode of the source on cnn
plus it's just a few weeks after we
launched
cassie hunt who left a job at msnbc for
cnn plus stated that some of her staff
left stable jobs and some moved across
the country and she noted that all of
them took a huge risk
[Music]
so why did nobody watch all the focus
groups and surveys may have told cnn
managers that the idea was valid but
watching content for free in a
controlled setting is different from
having to pay for it
cnn although a large legacy brand
doesn't really mean all that much
anymore they aren't as important as they
were in the 1980s and 90s the market
just didn't think that the programming
on cnn plus was enough value when
compared to free tv other internet
content or other streaming platforms for
that matter
apple tv peacock disney plus paramount
plus hbo max netflix and hulu all make
for stiff competition
cnn plus was just another six dollars a
month for politics and b grade content
it was too little too late
cnn executives struggle to navigate a
rapidly changing market a market where
consumer habits are unstable and this
all just shows what happens when you get
it wrong
so let's take a look at some lessons as
i said in my episode about the failure
of quibby criticizing is easy but
building is hard
that being said what are some lessons
here here are four quick ones
the first lesson would have been don't
lean on brand recognition alone there's
no guarantee of that working especially
in a rapidly evolving market
the second lesson is obvious make better
content that appeals to the target
audience although that's much easier
said than done
number three build trust if cnn plus was
to succeed they would first have to get
the fundamentals right they would need
to build brand trust among all americans
not just 50 of them
for this to happen there would need to
be as close to unbiased reporting as
possible each story should show the
complete picture and not substitute fact
for opinion
for the what about is out there this
isn't just a cnn problem the same goes
for fox news 2 but the topic here is
obviously cnn
and the fourth and final lesson clearer
internal communication may have also
helped prevent this disaster discovery
and warner media had their own plans for
streaming services so when it became
clear that the merger was happening the
cnn plus content should have been
absorbed into the existing services
instead of limping along as a standalone
service
the lack of internal communication and
friction prevented cnn plus from being
integrated well into the wider business
plan of both parent companies
so all in all the cnn brand may have
been hurt badly by this i'd even bet
that more people have heard of the cnn
plus disaster than cnn plus itself the
whole saga leaves a question mark over
cnn's digital presence at a time when
americans are stopping to watch cable tv
so what do you guys think did you even
hear about cnn plus
it really is a cutthroat environment in
the streaming world even netflix is
starting to struggle as we're going to
see in the next episode
so before i go just some quick
housekeeping i talked about this saga
and much more in the latest episode of
my podcast which you can check out in
the description below
i also just passed 5 000 followers on
spotify for my music so thanks to
everyone who's taken a listen
anyway that's it from me
my name is dagogo and you've been
watching cold fusion and i'll catch you
again soon for the next episode
cheers guys
have a
good oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
cold fusion
it's new thinking